hey Game of Thrones fans think story
here with a quick breakdown of some of
the latest photos released by HBO for
this Sunday's episode four and they
might give us some additional clues as
to where the rest of the season is going
I want to get right into it and start
with a photo that I think tells us the
most it's this one of Danny Mis and I
and Varys and what appears to be the
library of Winterfell the same library
Arya dodged the zombies in the last
episode and it seems like they've had
some time to remove all the bodies
they're likely discussing their next
plan of attack and you can see King's
Landing here surrounded by Circe's read
troops
it seems Cersei has learned the lessons
of Blackwater Bay in the loot train
attack and has decided to completely
surround King's Landing with Euron's
fleet and the golden company in the
preview we see flocks of citizens
rushing into the city so it looks like
her plan is to sit it out and let Danny
and the gang come to her but how did
Danny get a hold of this information
my guess lies in front of Varys here who
we see has a bunch of opened Raven
squirrels in front of them Varys has
spies all over the kingdom so they're
likely from him and if you zoom in super
close you can even make out what appears
to be a part of the sigil for house
Martell remember in season seven olaria
sin was forced to watch the death of her
daughter tyene in the red keep so don't
count house Martell out and a return of
ilaria in the next few episodes they all
seem to be listening to what is likely
John Tyrion Sansa and all the other big
names involved in the attack on King's
Landing with a shot from the preview
having Dany say we have won the Great
War
now we will win the last war the second
photo also seen in the preview is Danny
looking upward with drogon in the
background this is likely at the feeding
ground where they're kept which we saw
in episode 1 and my guess is that she's
looking upward at Ragle the other dragon
we also have a picture of the Targaryen
fleet and I'm wondering if Yara Greyjoy
will end up taking over this battalion
there's also this shot of Cersei wearing
her Lannister crimson red with urine in
the background she's wearing her
Lannister pendant overlooking the crowds
coming in with the mountain keeping
watch from behind the last four photos
I'm not gonna go into great detail
because there's not much to really
explain in them but they all take place
at what appears to be a funeral for all
the dead that died during the Battle of
Winterfell I think it's safe to assume
this will occur more so in the beginning
of the episode since we get this footage
of Danny cheering later on but with
three more hour-long episodes to go it's
gonna be interesting to see how they'll
top last week thanks for watching this
quick video like and subscribe and check
out my other breakdown videos below as
always I'll be coming out with my
episode 4 breakdown as soon as I can
hopefully Monday morning I'll be
drinking a lot of coffee and remember
daddy loves you very much